Speaker 1: We're already seeing and we're
going to continue to see a massive increase
in gas prices, and this is going to be dramatically
accelerated because the United States will
announce today.
By the time you watch today's show, listen
to today's podcast.
It may already have been announced the U.S.
will ban oil from Russia, and the European
Union plans to reduce by two thirds the amount
of oil purchased from Russia.
We are already at record high gas prices and
this is only going to get worse.
And I'm going to talk about all aspects of
this.
I'll talk about the political.
I will talk about the technological, the climate
change component and the economic.
But let's start with the big news today.
The U.S. is expected today to announce a ban
on Russian oil.
The White House updated President Joe Biden's
schedule to include an announcement of additional
steps the U.S. will take to hold Russia accountable
for its war on Ukraine.
Those remarks will be delivered at the White
House today, and the expectation is a ban
on imports of Russian oil, which would cut
about eight percent of America's annual supply.
Now I want to remind everybody we hear this
talking point from the right.
We were energy independent under Trump, and
now we no longer are.
The truth is that in the last couple of years
of Trump, as well as last year under Joe Biden,
the US produced as much oil as it used.
But that doesn't mean we only use our own
oil.
Some of the oil we we produce, we export and
we also import.
So even though total production and consumption
were roughly equal the last couple of years
of Trump and Biden.
That is true.
But also, oil is imported from Russia regularly.
It's about eight percent of American oil consumption,
and that is going to stop.
That is already caused oil prices to spike.
In addition, the European Union is pledging
to cut Russian gas imports by two third.
Did I say oil before I meant to say gas?
The EU is pledging to cut Russian gas imports
by two thirds before the end of the year,
and that will also have an impact on energy
prices, gas rather than oil.
On top of this, shell will no longer by Russian
oil nor Russian gas.
Shell said it is breaking completely, with
Russia's giant energy industry halting all
purchases of Russian crude oil immediately
and shutting service stations in the country.
The UK based company last week announced it
was dumping investments in Russia, said it
is abandoning all trade in Russian fossil
fuels to align with government guidance.
Russia is warning of $300 oil and threatening
to cut off European gas if the West bans energy
imports.
And now Europe is saying, well, we're cutting
down by two thirds anyway, so Russia looking
to escalate and threaten and believe me, I
mean three.
I'm against the use of fossil fuels.
I believe our transition to renewables has
been pathetically slow and hindered by bad
or lack of policy in large oil.
Consuming Western nations are all of it, and
I can't ignore that $300 oil and what it would
do to gas prices and home heating.
Gasoline prices and home heating would be
devastating to anyone who is in a financially
precarious or even, you know, balanced, but
not exactly a surplus economic situation.
And we are going to talk about that now.
We are already seeing we are already seeing
record gas prices.
The average is now right around four 19 per
gallon.
And if you go back over the last 10 years,
gas got close to for about 394 back in 2012,
about 369 in 2014.
This is the highest that gas prices have been
in 10 years.
So where do we even start?
First and foremost, we have to remember the
political how can American presidents impact
gas prices?
Gas prices are up globally, and there are
lots of people who just want to blame Joe
Biden.
This is very stupid now.
Fact check me on this.
I don't play politics with gas prices when
gas prices are low under a Democrat.
I say presidents have very little to do with
gas prices when gas prices are low.
Under a Republican, I say presidents have
very little to do when gas is high.
Under a Republican or a Democratic president,
I say presidents don't have very much to do
with gas prices.
Fact check me on it.
This is a very dumb political football.
What can presidents do to impact gas prices?
OK.
One.
An American president can say We're going
to.
War against an oil producing country, usually
that raises gas prices when we go to war with
a country that produces oil.
It's potentially going to disrupt the supply.
So when an American president says let's invade
like, for example, you know, the first Iraq
war, prices tend to go up.
Number two, a president can change gasoline
taxes raise or lower, and they can't unilaterally
do it, but a president can advocate for that.
And if gas taxes go up, then gas prices go
up and OK, so that's number two and then number
three, and this is the most commonly discussed
one.
There's this thing called the Strategic Petroleum
Reserve, and a president can release oil from
the Strategic Petroleum Reserve, which will
cause a small decrease in the price of oil
and eventually gas.
Or it will slow down the increase if gas prices
are increasing really quickly so presidents
can do very, very little.
And this is global.
It's happening everywhere.
So if your priority is blaming Biden, I don't
even want to hear from you because it's just
not even substantive.
The more pressing question is number one,
this again exposes how humiliatingly woefully
behind we have been on getting off of oil.
Now I know it's like, Oh, you're going to
do that, you're going to, you're going to
be that guy.
David, I understand that transitioning off
of oil takes time.
Transitioning off of natural gas, takes time
putting solar panels on roofs and having electric
heating and cooking and electric cars so that
you get off fossil fuels other than for the
production of all of the stuff that you use.
I get that that takes time, but we also need
to remember that we didn't make much progress
under Obama.
We didn't make almost any progress under Trump.
We continue to have completely inaccurate
gas prices.
In other words, our gas prices don't even
come close to reflecting the true cost of
gasoline on the environment and on the economy
and on society.
So it were it's been pathetic.
And I also understand how if you're a family
that, like 40 percent of families in the United
States, can't meet an unexpected $400 expense
without taking on debt, putting out a credit
card or whatever.
I understand that if gas prices go up to five
or six dollars a gallon, which five 20 is
one of the numbers that's being thrown around,
average gallon could go to five 20, and you
need heating oil to heat your home because
you don't have one of these new fancy electric
heat pumps and solar panels and all that you're
still paying for oil.
I get how you'll probably end up going into
debt just to fuel your car and heat your home
so we can hold both at the same time.
But let's at least be accurate in terms of
who is to blame for this and the real role
of presidents.
And once the announcement is made and more
accurate forecasts are made, we
will
follow
that up.